wir als westliche staaten haben auch
eine verantwortung uns dafür einzusetzen
dass es wieder verhandlungen gibt und
nicht das zu tun was damals passierte
seelands hier unter druck zu setzen dass
er keine kompromisse man auch einmal
gerne frau warte ich noch auf ihrer
ihrer angst eingehen eben schon
angesprochen wenn das in der ukraine die
restliche welt damit in den krieg
reinzieht sie haben kürzlich gesagt herr
scholz ich will kein held sein ich habe
angst vor dem krieg glauben sie dass es
möglich wäre dass im bereich des
möglichen liegt dass der dritte
weltkrieg ausbricht also ich fürchte
zumindest dass es
wahrscheinlicher ist als jemals seit dem
ende des kalten krieges und das muss
nicht mal ein plan sein also ich glaube
auch nicht dass putin morgen auf den
atom knopfdruck da ist auch viel
drohpotenzial und so weiter aber wir
liefern waffen wir bilden ukrainische
soldaten aus was ist wenn russland zum
beispiel eine waffenlieferung eine
panzer oder was auch immer an greift
bevor sie ukrainisches territorium
erreichen schießen wir dann aus vollen
rohren zurück dann sind wir mit russland
im krieg und relativ sicher dass sagen
militärexperten ist wenn es einen krieg
zwischen dem naht zwischen der nato und
russland gibt dann wird dieser krieg
irgendwann nuklear eskalieren weil
russland konventionell keine chance
hätte in einem solchen krieg und das ist
eine unglaubliche gefahr und ich sehe
auch zum beispiel jetzt finnland wird in
die nato also finnland schweden werden
eintreten russland hat angedroht dass er
das sie dann kaliningrad aufrüsten das
heißt immer mehr militärpotenzial steht
sich gegenüber und auch im kalten krieg
war immer die angst dass mal ein
missverständnis also einfach ein
computerfehler weil die vorwarnzeiten so
kurz sind dazu führen kann dass eine auf
den vermeintlichen gegenschlag knopf
drückt und es ist gar kein gegenschlag
und auch dann ist nokia europa also
sowas von verehrt und und es werden
millionen menschen sterben also ich
finde das ganz gefährlich was aktuell
passiert und wir müssen aufpassen dass
wir uns nicht immer mehr in diesem krieg
einziehen lassen ich glaube angst ist
kein guter ratgeber bei der frage
wie man mit diesem krieg umgeht und ich
glaube man muss vor allem sich immer die
frage stellen was wäre die alternative
gehen wir mal durch wenn wir keine
waffen liefern wenn die usa keine waffen
liefern dann würde die ukraine diesen
krieg verlieren dann würde russland ganz
schnell wieder in kiew sein und dann
würden sehr viele botschaft dort
entstehen und es ist so wenn wir uns das
anschauen und überlegen was die
russische armee in diesen dörfern in
diesen städten gemacht hat
vergewaltigung
menschen zivilisten erschossen auf
grausamste weise getötet dann ist es
doch unsere aufgabe alles zu tun
wirklich alles zu tun dass das nicht
passiert ja und dafür muss man den krieg
beenden also in kriegen ja natürlich
dass man durch wahrscheinlich muss ich
mir gestern
geschehen und deswegen muss man doch
alles daran setzen das wäre ja das
ergebnis auch eines waffenstillstands
natürlich dass die russischen truppen
abziehen also dann wird es auch keine
verbrechen mehr geben und wenn sie sagen
die sind dann morgen wieder in kiew sie
waren ja nicht in kiew auch ohne die
waffenlieferungen wahnsinnig in kiew
reisen ein großteil natürlich gab es
auch schon so ein sehr stark
hochgerüstete ablassen die führung der
usa natürlich wurde kiew mit westlichen
waffen verteidigt unter anderem auch mit
deutschen panzer abwehr
panzerabwehrraketen da gab es natürlich
westliche war ja weil die wir haben ja
damals noch nichts geliefert das heißt
die kinder vier und ist eine relevante
rüstungsindustrie die sind ja selber
rüstungsexporteur vor dem krieg gewesen
also es ist ja nicht so dass da ein ganz
ohne ausgang aber es ist ein vollkommen
aber ist und auch
geheimdiensterkenntnisse zum beispiel
der usa die geteilt wurden mit den
ukrainern ohne westliche waffen das
sagen alle experten natürlich
die
ergebnisse waren wichtiger als die
waffen also die waren offensichtlich
wirklich wichtig weil sie haben ja
offensichtlich mit ihren aufklärungs
geheimdiensten tatsächlich auch dazu
geführt dass dann eben auch generelle
getroffen wurden usw also das hat ja
stattgefunden nur die frage ist was
wollen wir was will deutschland was will
die nato was wollen die westlichen
länder wollen wir dass wir jetzt einen
langen langen krieg dort in der ukraine
mit immer mehr waffen munition ihren und
nehmen dabei in kauf dass jeden tag
menschen sterben dass immer mehr
menschen sterben das auch je brutaler
unsere waffen sind desto brutaler die
kriegsführung von putin wird oder sagen
wir wir setzen alles daran
und ehrlich gesagt finde ich ist das
auch eine aufgabe der europäer nein
natürlich sehen also wenn herr beiden
sagt doch überall wir müssen uns auf
einen langen krieg einstellen oder so
will frei sein doch wir wollen mit
russland maximal schwächen das ist ein
anderes kriegsziel ich meine wir haben
das doch vorhin gehört die krise und
maximal zu spät aber das wird doch
gesagt das hat doch der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister
sagt aber es sind auch einem erstmal und
die russische armee und natürlich ist
und muss unser ziel sein diese russische
armee zusammen mit der ukraine maximal
zu schwächen damit ist er ist doch die
hat doch ein potenzial von ich meine
wenn die eine generalmobilmachung haben
das ist ein so bevölkerungsreichstes
land und die haben auch eine ganz starke
rüstungsindustrie die bauen selber
wieder waffen und sie bauen kann sie
sehen doch manch die russische armee
bereits jetzt ist sie ist nicht modern
also ausgestattet aber dass sie immer
wieder auch militärisches gerät selber
auch herstellen kann auch in der ukraine
einsetzen kann ich meine die situation
ist doch seit dem märz sei damals die
fahndung geplatzt sind zu heute nicht
für die ukraine vorteilhafter als online
aus kiel fahren sie damals schon weg das
war das war schon aber sie sind ja
langsam im don was natürlich vorgerückt
und in syrien würde ich gerne einmal
herrn richter noch mal um seine
expertise betten und fragen wie hoch
denn die atomare gefahr ist
also es ist ja nett dass sie mich noch
an der diskussion beteiligen vielen dank
für
die atomare gefahr ist natürlich immer
da wenn man tatsächlich von einem
szenario ausgeht in dem das bündnis und
russland sich in einem offenen krieg
befinden es ist ziel und auch aussage
klare aussage auch der bundesregierung
aber auch von beiden gewesen dass man
nicht kriegt teil werden wolle man kann
man sich auf einen rechtlichen
standpunkt stellen dass
der natürlich sagt man kann sich wenn
man angegriffen wird individuell und
kollektiv verteidigen
insofern wäre sogar eine militärische
beteiligung möglich aber das völkerrecht
ist das eine und die praxis und der
pragmatismus und die gefahren für die
sicherheit in europa sind das andere
natürlich müssen wir alles vermeiden was
in diese richtung der eskalation läuft
aber auch unterhalb dieser schwelle gibt
es natürlich eine andere art der
eskalation die liegt eher an der
ressourcen bildung natürlich ist
russland in der lage über mobilmachung
dennoch weitere ressourcen zu
mobilisieren
wir sollten auch den operativen gewinn
oder sieg in kharkiv bzw in kiew jetzt
nicht so überbewerten dass wir das jetzt
schon zum sieg über die russische armee
erklären im donbass ist die russische
armee immer noch stabil und wir haben
dabei vielleicht auch übersehen und die
platte dass sie im süden hin es
geschafft haben einen landkorridor zu
bilden von der krim bis zum bass und
auch noch westlich mit einem finger in
richtung carlsson diese operation
scheint auch noch stabil zu sein das
heißt auch unterhalb der ebene einer
direkten kriegsbeteiligung von
bündnispartnern sehe ich die gefahr
einer weiteren eskalation durch die
mobilisierung von ressourcen das heißt
das ergibt sich dann eine
materialschlacht die auf der westlichen
seite natürlich durchaus gefüttert
werden kann aber man sollte hier was
dann die unterschätzen das heißt wir
kommen hier nicht raus aus dem zwang zu
verhandeln und leider ist es oft in
kriegen so dass die verhandlungs
elemente schon zu beginn des krieges
vorliegen und wir haben ja schon auf die
kompromissbereitschaft salans kies
verwiesen aber gestern habe ich gehört
dass der außenminister kollege das ziel
ins auge gefasst hat einer
gegenoffensive nicht nur im juni
generell sondern auch um die krim wieder
zu erobern und das sind natürlich escala
torische momente wo ich dann eher denke
dass die eskalation auf beiden seiten so
zunimmt dass die opfer natürlich auch zu
nehmen da beides weder die eskalation in
richtung kriegs ausweitung noch diese
art der materialschlacht in unserem
interesse sein kann glaube ich schon wir
müssen uns bemühen die ukraine so zu
unterstützen dass sie ihre souveränität
verteidigen kann aber wir dürfen nicht
jetzt kriegsziele als nicht kriegswirren
der parteien formulieren die weit
darüber hinausgehen und dann geht auch
um eine skala torische das potenzial
haben das heißt ich setze darauf dass
warfen dazu führen dass die souveränität
verteidigt wird dann muss aber auch der
druck kommen tatsächlich ernsthaft über
diese elemente zu verändern die wir
bereits gesprochen haben hier kann wir
vielleicht noch mehr tun aber natürlich
wird auch unterhalb der öffentlichkeit
unterhalb der oberfläche also da schon
einiges passieren um diesen kompromiss
frieden herbeizuführen ich bin mir noch
nicht sicher ob alle alliierte hier da
wirklich von einer von demselben
gesamtplatz -ing